It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today here for our 166th episode of BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
It's been a little while, but BAU BAU!
We're doing much better!
But, well, for Ruffians, maybe this is your first time joining us here for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians joining us for the first time today!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short, four-night morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Right now, FUWAMOCO Morning will be brought to you temporarily on Mondays once a week!
So we can get a bit more balance!
I'm here to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please take a note of the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
There's been a lot happening, so we wanted to be able to, you know, share them with you, Ruffians, to be able to see you, to be able to start the week off on the right paw!
So, let's do that, okay?
BAU BAU!
Well, Moco-chan.
Do you have some of the things you want to share with the Ruffians?
Yeah, important information!
Important information!
Let's take a look, Moco-chan.
Well... Ruffians... Do you need to say Pero in the comments, too?
It's like you're summoning him or something.
Pero summoning!
Ruffians.
Well, there has been another Pero sighting.
It's not because you're saying anything in the comments of the Ruffians!
Well, let's check it out, I guess.
BAU BAU!
Where is this?
Huh?
Good Pero.
He's just a big nasty pest Ruffians.
But, uh, I guess you know your anime ex-boy.
Ah, anime ex-boy!
Maybe you felt a little bit happy seeing a familiar face there.
You know it's a big event.
Yeah, lots of people.
Just Ruffians!
Don't be a fool!
No, okay!
Don't give him anything!
Don't even acknowledge him!
Yeah.
Got it!
You know, you might have been asking for food.
It's nicely done, but...
Ruffians, this is just the beginning, okay?
He'll stop swiping it right from you, okay?
You have to be careful, okay?
You gave him your credit card!
Well, that was your decision, Ruffians.
These situations, Ruffians, I think we've said many times.
It's best just to ignore him.
Don't give him any time of day, okay?
Told you!
You should know by now!
Yeah, got it.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Don't fall for Pero's tricks, right?
Yeah.
And yet this happens.
BAU BAU.
You'll be okay.
BAU BAU!
Just ignore him, okay?
Wow, Ruffians!
I think maybe there's a few Ruffians here that are like, FUWAMOCO, it's been a little bit since I saw you last!
Hi!
And that's because FUWAMOCO, we sleep.
We are sick.
FUWAMOCO We've been away for the past few days because we go really sick.
FUWAMOCO But you know we've been taking it easy.
Getting lots and lots of sleep.
FUWAMOCO And you know we made sure to go to the doctor too.
FUWAMOCO And the doctor, she looked at us and said, FUWAMOCO Oh yeah, you're sick.
Yeah, that's all.
We got some important medicines and then we've been stuck in a doghouse since.
It's been rough though because Ruffians!
We wanted to do so many things together with you!
And then now we have to stay put.
That's all.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Pretty okay.
I haven't been coughing really or anything, so not that much.
But, let's take it easy!
And then you know, also get back to a number of things that we need to catch up on, you know?
Especially, you know, there's been a bunch of summer fun going on!
And my second anniversary is coming up too!
So, lots and lots of stuff!
I'm really excited!
But thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for all the help as we were recovering too, so...
It made us feel much better knowing that you're thinking about us and we went alone, so... Thank you, Ruffians!
No, no, daijoubu, daijoubu!
Chotto yowai dake!
Mou chotto ne, yasumu kara ne.
But there's lots of fun summer stuff coming up, so... Please look forward to it together with us, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Well, you know, fun summer stuff kind of.
I don't really know exactly what that is, but then... Did you hear, Ruffians?
Huh?
Maybe not.
Well, hololive Summer is back this time as hololive Natsuperidon!
Yes!
BAU BAU!
You know, there's a bunch of fun things going on right now.
But to recap a little bit of what's happened
So fun!
Wow!
We are on the official channel!
Kicking off the start of the hololive to paradise!
All together with Mari-senpai, Noel-senpai, Lappa-senpai, and Ori-senpai!
Yeah!
We had lots of fun!
We played a bunch of games, you know.
Watermelon.
Coconut soccer.
There's watermelons.
Yeah.
Watermelon.
Right!
The prizes, right?
I was looking forward to it.
Plus, I was looking forward to it too.
And then... We went over prizes.
We were excited because Moco-chan, you were on one team.
And I was on the other team.
So no matter what, we couldn't get prizes no matter what.
We both made it lose each time.
We get the prize!
Maybe the prizes didn't make it to our paws.
Where are the prizes?
I was looking forward to it.
I pressed it, but I was like, it's okay, they'll definitely be the prizes.
We had a bunch of fun together with them and then we're able to share some details about all the summer stuff happening!
And you might have already seen too, but there's some special shorts going up on every member's channel and all these two of us have these two shorts!
The whole nuts of peace!
We see we can do it now!
Whole nuts of peace!
Thank you!
Bye-bye!
Please take a look if you haven't yet.
If you have yet, please take a look too.
And also you know, I think the rest of the Advent, not just Nerissa, Nerissa will be waiting for you still.
There are also Biboo, Shiori.
And there's a big calendar!
There's gonna be new shorts going up every day!
So please take a look at that, you know?
Or maybe go check out your other favorite Yoshimen's channel to see if there's more shorts out yet!
You're gonna search on FUWAMOCO channel, huh?
You're already here.
You don't need to search it up.
Right.
I'll just click select.
FUWAMOCO channel.
Let's look at the shorts right.
And you know, FUWAMOCO.
We also appeared in last week's hologram episode.
Celebrating the start to a new holo-natsu paradise!
Right!
Beach attire.
BAU BAU!
You can check that out for some more fun together with our senpai.
There's also a new hologram too!
That one was wow!
Back in traditional hologram fashion!
The new one with Calli-senpai!
I understood Japanese and English and woah my brain!
Just try looking at it!
If you tried watching it, maybe you should try again.
But there's also going to be a special Honatsu Gekiatsu Midsummer Song Relay Challenge!
A karaoke relay starting from...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
But there's gonna be a lot of hololive singing, including us, FUWAMOCO-chan!
We'll be there!
We'll be singing at 6.40pm and at 11.40pm PT on the 25th.
So we hope that you'll be there cheering for us!
I don't know.
Moco-chan, we haven't decided what we're gonna sing yet, right?
No.
It's summer though, so we should probably sing some summery songs, right?
Ruffians, do you have any suggestions?
Ah!
See you soon!
Kiss Me is not a summer song!
Seasonal Halation.
Right on time.
Oh, Shinkiro.
Ruffians want some classics.
Summer, summer.
Makana Chikai.
It's good if you get a songbird.
A solo!
Is it gonna be a solo utawaku?
Have to see!
Who knows?
We haven't really decided yet, have we?
FUWAMOCO!
Can we take a look at what's happening next?
That is the whole FUWAMOCO competition!
It's happening at 2am PT on the 26th!
Yes!
FUWAMOCO we don't enroll, thank goodness!
Our tails would be crunched, huh?
Crunched.
Yeah, so you can check that out.
I think it's... I'm not too sure what channel it's on.
Maybe the hololive official channel?
Why would anyone want to watch butt sumo?
I don't know why, but why?
But we'll figure it out.
What are we figuring out?
Next thing!
Afterwards!
At around... What time?
What time?
At 4AM PT on the 26th, there's going to be a whole lot's of Queen Tournament happening in VRChat!
FUWAMOCO, we're gonna be participating too, so please cheer us on!
We're getting fun minigames!
Yeah, and you can play it too right now in VRChat!
The world's open!
So please go give it a time!
Maybe you can give us some tips too, Ruffians!
And then afterwards...
FUWAMOCO!
We're actually singing in Aizome Summertime 2!
We're so happy and honored to be a part of the theme song this year.
And the song has already been released so you can go check it out.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
26th is the big day for hololive Japan so we hope that you'll join us there, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
There's one more thing to Ruffians.
Another big part unveiling of Holonatsu this year is everybody has swimsuits!
And we kind of made quite a bit of a stir because fashion statement.
I'm bathing so it's like de-den!
Fashion statement.
Reasonable if you crashed on an uninhabited island from a helicopter.
These are bathing suits!
Bathing suits Ruffians!
And you know, you know that you're so excited for bathing suits!
And here they are!
Just like you wanted, right?
Walk the runway.
Yeah, go Abbey, go!
Yeah!
See... You know, staffers are, they're like, huh... Advent, what about this?
And we thought that was funny.
We're like, okay, uh... I don't think we understood the scope of this.
We didn't.
And now... It's maybe not as funny.
It's where we are!
Just a prank!
Yup!
Here we are!
And now for a howl of a day too!
I love everybody's very cute bathing suits!
There's us.
We're not criminals.
Yeah.
That's how we ended up here.
You can't take your eyes off of us!
We're-
You're not supposed to see us, we're supposed to get away and, you know, do we steal your heart?
BAU BAU!
But Pero!
Why Pero Ruffians?
Pero is already wearing nothing normally.
Moco-chan, you didn't need to point that out.
Just saying!
BAU BAU!
I hope there's a lot of sunscreen otherwise, you know.
Sunlight.
BAU BAU!
My turn won't do summer final camp!
I'm glad you like the FUWAMOCO fans.
After all, you know.
Our first bathing suits!
Yeah, we've been looking forward to them for so long, so... BAU BAU!
And recently... Ruffians!
We had some fun in Holo Earth together!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
We are really happy to be able to finally jump into hololive and, you know, met a place that all of our cover has been waiting on for a few years for a while now.
It's a bit of a sandbox where we can join all together to come together and play and, you know, be able to spend time together.
Yeah!
So we are really happy to be able to try on a bunch of different clothes.
Even some clothes that you made!
And!
Even make some codes ourselves too!
BAU BAU!
We have our first item as well if you'd like to, you know, try out FUWAMOCO coordinates.
Yeah!
I own BAU BAU sweater!
It was really fun doing not just trying on all the different outfits and trying this hairstyle, that hairstyle, but then there's also the survival mode.
We really had a bunch of fun together with you Ruffians and we're looking forward to playing more!
Huh?
The scooter?
Baby, come race the Ruffians in the future, Moco-chan!
But there's just so many things that we can do together in it and we're really looking forward to all the updates and the growth that there will be in the future too.
So we hope that you'll join us again in the future for more holo-earth Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
We have something exciting coming up too!
We're gonna be performing in Hong Kong for ACGHK coming up very soon!
BAU BAU!
You know what, the event is one of the biggest ones in Hong Kong!
I've seen it a lot online and it looks like lots and lots of fun!
It's gonna be happening on June 28th at 1.45pm at the main anime festival stage!
We're gonna be doing a bit of a Q&A and then a mini Rock n' Rawr Party as well!
So we're really looking forward to being able to spend some time with the Ruffians at FUWAMOCO!
We're looking forward to seeing all the fun Advent stuff, cute cosplayers, and seeing you all there as well!
We're really really excited!
July 28th.
July.
Don't eat the past Ruffians!
Although I can't believe that July is almost over too.
Don't say it.
But we are looking forward to the unofficial FUWAMOCO World Tour.
It continues!
BAU BAU!
And there is also another big update!
hololive English, we're having our third concert coming up!
All for one!
And there's a big update!
De-den!
Look at the key mission!
All of us, all together, all for one!
And you see...
Justice.
Justice!
Yeah!
They have their idol outfits.
Right!
And this time our outfits are a little bit different.
We're in the colorized outfits.
But they're black.
Everyone is wearing the black variant.
And we all have a matching hair accessory too!
The cute ribbon!
We're all FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
We're really really happy to be able to be here all together with everybody.
But there's also some more updates too!
Merchandise!
It comes with a t-shirt!
And then a lightstick!
But there's also a very cool FUWAMOCO emblem too!
You can actually put the sticker on the back of the lightstick too!
I think you only get the sticker in the pack.
Right, so you'll have to get your paws on a Ruffian.
But it's nice to know being together with Moco-chan.
Can you imagine if there's a Fuwawa one and then a Mococo one?
Fuwamoco.
So, we hope that you'll get your paws on it so you'll be able to wear it at the concert.
You know, use the lightstick at the concert too, Ruffians.
And there's a lot more other merch as well so please check it out online at the kiosk.
FUWAMOCO!
What a really exciting door!
All for one, this song was revealed!
It was revealed, Ruffians!
Yes!
Did you listen to it?
Maybe it's been a bit hidden?
The song is out!
Yes, the song is out!
Please go take a listen!
The MV!
Well, there's still maybe no MV yet.
But the song is out so we really love it if you could listen to it lots and lots and get all prepared for the concert!
We're having a bunch of fun all together with us.
We've been working so so hard!
Lots of practice!
So we hope that you'll get all pumped up and that
We'll have an amazing time at the end of August.
Together all as one!
All for one!
It's so blizzard to it.
Okay?
BAU BAU!
I'm really looking forward to it.
August 23rd, 24th!
There's also streaming tickets to Ruffians if you can't make it to New York.
So we hope that you'll be cheering for us there too.
Okay?
Two days!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Wow, Moco-chan, you know what?
It's been a little while since the last FUWAMOCO Morning.
Ruffians!
How does summer have you doing?
What?
Exactly!
How does summer have you doing?
Yeah!
Does that make sense?
It's very hot, that's an appropriate answer.
Someone has me doing okay, thank you!
You get it!
Si!
BAU BAU!
Someone has me doing okay, I'm glad!
You haven't slept for more than 36 hours!
Sleep!
You'd be surprised what flow it has!
It's winter.
It's winter, it's winter, okay.
I don't know about that.
I was only there for a moment.
But it's okay now.
Because you're here.
Ruffians!
I know it's that time again!
What?
I'm still recovering.
So it's time for a mini Pup Talk.
I hear that here is safe for me.
Mococo!
Ruffians!
Do your best, okay?
I know the days are hot and long, but you can do it!
Just know, we're always cheering for you, okay?
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
Let's do our best to kill all the FUWAMOCOs!
Thank you!
Thank you for all the FUWAMOCOs!
Let's take a look at some of the FUWAMOCOs!
We'll start with the Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is...
Chispita!
BAU BAU!
So cute!
Tiny!
Look, the ears are big but everything else is so tiny!
It's not even as big as a present, you!
Everything is so tiny!
Look, Chispita's ears.
They're not so tiny.
They're about as big as my ears here though.
But everything else is so tiny.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
I don't even know what that is.
It's a pet shish pita with maybe three fingers.
Three fingers, maybe two.
A full hand is a little bit scary.
Maybe it's like the pinky pet.
Yeah, this is a small dog.
It is a small dog.
It's shish pita!
How does shish pita BAU BAU, Moco-chan?
Oh, it's so tiny, I can almost not hear it.
That's how it sounds.
So tiny.
Cheese Pita is so tiny, I was thinking we're almost friends to go, so I smiled, but there's no FUWAMOCO friends to go.
This is Cheese Pita friends to go.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
Maybe selfish.
I hope that she's picked up a pickaxe as her OC too!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Next we have a regular corner.
Today I went on a walk.
And we have De-den!
That's so crazy!
Oh my gosh.
Temple ruins.
Beautiful!
It looks like it's almost out of a video game!
Yeah!
My show was unforgettable, you know, being able to see up close in person!
Wow!
And look at the clouds too!
Everything's just beautiful!
Wonderful weather!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And next we have our Question of the Day!
Our Question of the Day is... De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
I have a question.
What do you think about Ruffians from all around the world interacting with each other?
How do you feel knowing that people from different countries and languages are connecting because of you?
Um... It makes us feel...
Very very very happy!
Really happy Ruffians!
You know, we really really love Ruffians from all over the world!
Maybe come, you know, close?
Connect, you know?
You know, maybe practice languages together, you know?
Like, I'm learning Japanese, you know?
I'm learning English.
BAU BAU is in Spanish!
Ruffians are all over the world!
So it makes us really happy when we're able to go to places like Hong Kong and be able to meet a bunch of different Ruffians from all over the place!
We hope that you'll be able to go and visit other places too and hopefully be able to meet lots of different Ruffians as well.
Thank you Ruffians!
It really warms our hearts seeing you be able to just have fun interacting together on Twitter too.
So you wanna bubble a real life one day too?
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for always being the Ruffians that we're so proud of.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
Remember FUWAMOCO Morning!
You're a big part of it.
FUWAMOCO Morning, you made it together with us!
You made it!
That's all!
We're always looking for more Doggy of the Days!
For your vlogs, questions,
Please send us your questions!
And Pero Sightings too, okay?
If they have a car.
Don't forget to use the hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
Bye bye!
Thank you Ruffians!
Thank you!
Well, our next stream, right now, we're still just healing up and we're getting caught up on a number of things.
We have some big recordings this week too, so we'll do our best, but Ruffians, you'll see us next day in the whole Natsukai Okimele, okay?
Okay!
BAU BAU!
I'm FUWAMOCO today!
Your FUWAMOCO is... It's BAU BAU Summer Healing!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Yamamoto!
BAU BAU!
Tohifu.
Mofukuro.
BAU BAU!
You are my oishi.
Midori.
BAU BAU!
Waisen.
Fireball.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU